[Musique]
bonsoir mesdames ressort une mazel
bonsoir messieurs bonsoir strasbourg et
bonsoir martin europe stop que bon
service et bien ce soir nous allons
encore essayer de faire grossir de petit
cochon rose et pour ce faire nous vous
proposons un petit régime alsacien à
base de choucroute de foie gras et j'en
passe pour la chaîne
c'est la couenne petit cochon ni de
maître capello on ne sait pas où ils
sont passés mais on a peut-être une
chance de les récupérer avant la fin
d'émission
cela ne vous donne pas trop fan marie
sissi si bien sûr mais il faut pas trop
que je mange parce que je crois aussi
bien et et nos invités je suppose qu'ils
en ont l'eau à la bouche à regarder
regard des américains
polly et moi on est on est amateur
vraiment on alasuak du loria condé coûte
rien qu'en écoutant absolue dans ma
carrière et robert rocca
[Applaudissements]
et également à la droite dannemarie
carrière nous retrouvons ce soir encore
jean-marie premier et encore avec la
tour en deux chevaux et puis alors
l'inquiétude ne gagne de plus en plus
parce que toujours pas de maître capello
ni le petit cochon que va-t-il se passer
s'ils n'arrivent pas à son petit cochon
y mon gars est avait pris la poudre
d'escampette et le voici avec 14 100
francs ce qui est bien maigre
ce qui est bien maigre et ne demande
qu'à grossir voici notre premier jeu
nous allons jouer tout donc avec le mot
notable que vous avez découvert dans vos
quotidiens les dernières nouvelles
d'alsace l'alsacien et estelle et flash
voilà premiers candidats première
candidate nous ne savons pas de toute
façon jean pierre des corps ont valu est
présenté oui non ils ont tous donné le
candidat qui va débuter
voilà qui est là d'ailleurs je pense que
vous l'apercevez et qui va prendre donc
le début de ce si je vous dis elle va
être suivi de nombreux candidats qui ont
préparé également de nombreuses listes
faites vers les listes un peu regardé
aulas c'est un beau mano zèle ni robert
rocca pour la première fois alors
mademoiselle anneaux un mot de cinq
lettres cinq lettres extraite du mot
notable non d'une prison où l'on doit
bien se porter la santé oui madame
travaux portuaires
ça commence sa lettre il est de notre
sous sol de l'estomac
pardon je ne fais pas tout seul de
l'estomac
andres comment pensent non madame p non
il ya encore pleinement nos tables
c'était quoi dans l'année de chercher
cette nuance et étalons l'estomac dans
les talons c'est vraiment la même chose
on est alors bien joué
s'il est en or si les temps alors il
n'intéresse pas la jument combien doit
aussi l'être s'il est étale en voilà
cinq ans robert oui oui j'adore ma roue
vingt ans nos clients mes clients voici
en trois lettres doublé pour mon oncle
en trois lettres des fois ton goût et
entonne ton canton qu'on mérite à
classer en cinq lettres bêtes à cornes
qui ont du coeur une élan et la wii mais
ne soufflait pas si fort on entendu
effectivement voilà cinq enfants quatre
lettres de sang désignent eux en quatre
lettres
si vous trouvez la solution vous en
aurez une bad en quatre lettres il faut
une note
ça rentre ensuite les facile alors
écoutez moi bien parce que c'est
important ce que je vais dire bon en
cinq lettres dans l'évangile précède
saint-luc gens non non top 5 est
terminée c'est une préposition selon les
bons sens tant attendez attendez
attendez n'ont pas connu cela en europe
et chantait subtil
voilà selon hé bien on continue
alors on continue je vous soit par les
images étaient moins partie à fourrure
serpentine en trois lettres fous rires
c'est moi comme en bois oui monsieur
bon déjà c'est gagnant jean-marie basel
iii lettres quand il est tard à c'est
déjà trop
ras-le-bol voilà que c'est beau tout ça
en bout trois lettres ou satan a le
permis de conduire
bâle est allé je compte jusqu'à deux
dates c'est trop tard bâle satan conduit
le bal c'est bien cette lettre on parle
souvent de on ne parle jamais de ses
années mais souvent de ces retours
là aussi on se dépêche une fois et on ne
souffle pas deux fois
je ne sais pas bâton les retours de
bâton voyez un retour de bâton et des
places de cinéma pour ces deux matches
les enfants puissent pas jouer s'il est
vraiment très facile en deux lettres un
anglais kindy pailhès à la halle aux
oreilles non il attend soupire est en
quatre lettres pernaut battant quatre
lettres à paires de souliers une fois et
deux fois et je suis je parie vient trop
noël somme le père noël père noël place
des cinémas pour ce candidat sort quatre
lettres non contents de les couper on
les bat comment sont pas contents de les
couper on les bat en 80 une les hommes
voient les hommes ont pas du tout non
donc non pas du tout chez les messieurs
les bleus et on bat les blés et ben
voilà au cinéma rien jean-marie en trois
lettres trois lettres eu cris de douleur
pour les taureaux olé olé voilà très
bien joué
ça t'arrive 7,8 on l'a en trois lettres
on préfère le gros après bien le gros le
sel ah bah écoute et vous voudriez voir
un or ni comment s'appelle et on vous
avait soufflé vous n'avez pas compris ce
bon alors le mot robert c'était c'était
le boulot évidemment et non celle le
gros sel ou de savoir-faire pas
forcément perdue monsieur maintenant à
moi en quatre lettres facile entre la
mouche et la guêpe
une fois le temps c'est ça bravo 950
francs jean-marie le temps en cinq
lettres en cinq lettres un peu plus
compliqué celui là employeurs à teinture
rice et feuilles peuvent vous faire
changer de couleur sinclair une fois
employé en teinture hisser feuilleton
nous faire changer de couleur 2 une idée
et 3 alors est-ce alors est à l'ouest
excellent pluriel reste rien su rien de
nouveau cinq lettres s'annonce à paris
chaque lettre grosses chaussures ou
petite baignoire sabot
bravo bien joué une fois de 3,36 gagné
55 lettres une définition poétique que
j'essaie de prêt vers la mer y est face
les pas des amants désunis que ce bout
une lettre en cinq lettres sable oui
mademoiselle
c'étaient les causes en trois lettres
j'en vois l'être s'il est en laine il
peut peser lourd
une fois deux fois et 3 il ne souffle
pas de toute façon c'est fini c'était le
bas le bas de laine le bas de l'économie
et s'est terminée à un vin est trop tard
pour ce monsieur c'est trop tard il
pourra jouer un autre jeu le bila encore
m le record établi hier n'a pas été
battu mais il ya quand même 12 gagnants
ce qui est très bon voilà eh bien il
fallait le dire bravo bravo encore à nos
candidats de strasbourg qui sont
vraiment très forts aussi je vous dis
espérons qu'ils seront aussi fort à
notre deuxième jeu
pour ce deuxième jeu trois candidates
tout d'abord la première
bonsoir madame prénom madame marie
jeanne marié bien sûr comme un enfant 4
votre profession madame je n'ai pas
élevé bien sûr les enfants c'est très
bien candidate numéro 2 madame bihan
sans sang bref l'avion à l'élève sa
petite fille et enfin troisième
candidate
madame michèle irène serveurs serveuses
et deux enfants
voilà donc trois candidates maurice
cerci jean-pierre alors veiller à ce que
les récepteurs de contrôle soit à couper
devant le candidat puisqu'il s'agit des
histoires connues et que nos trois
candidats sont bien sûr les éléments
d'une histoire très très connu
ils ne peuvent pas ignorer à vous de
déterminer de quelle histoire il s'agit
alors première candidate
vous êtes un homme et vous allez devoir
questionner ce même homme
représenté par robert rocca va vous
aider au maximum j'ai l'habitude depuis
plus longtemps ma mère bonjour ma chérie
alors deuxième candidate deuxième
candidate vous êtes vous un bâtiment
n'est ce pas et ce bâtiment c'est
également et marie carrière qui vous
aidera bâtiment bonsoir madame alors
mitraillé la de questions et troisième
candidate vous alors vous êtes un autre
homme ainsi que jean-marie palier qui
grâce à vous va découvrir votre identité
enfin c'est le concours jean marie haas
à lui que vous allez découvrir votre
identité
voilà c'est parti comme vous voulez oui
ça nous célèbre au oui oh oui nous
sommes très célèbre nous sommes fait un
nom et un prénom vivant non alors des
piles en tout cas pas l'impôt sur le
revenu allez-y poser des questions j'en
consomme du très célèbre très célèbre
wii
célèbre légendaire oui c'est plus
exactement légendaire que très célèbre
affaire c'est pareil mais légendaire oui
trouve nous trouvons-nous dans les
bandes dessinées à ma connaissance pas
mais c'est pas impossible si nani libre
il paraît dans les livres issa dans les
appareils comme dans les bandes
dessinées aussi mais ça mon un succès je
suis très peu cultivé je regarde la télé
je peux pas être partout
avons nous déjà passé à la télévision je
pense oui oui sûrement même dans un film
dans un film louis vous dirai pas le nom
de l'acteur qui nous représentait héros
des jeunes pardon un héros des jeunes
comme ça ça je me rapporte c'est terminé
c'est terminé pour notre première
candidate
voici notre seconde candidate qui elle
est un bâtiment
il marie carrière étant le même bâtiment
il reste à savoir lequel l'actif situé à
paris
ce bâtiment n'est pas situé à paris nos
en france
écoutez non non pas en france en europe
en europe oui très bonne question que ça
continue existe-t-il toujours oui oui
oui il y en a toujours
est ce un bateau ce n'est pas un bad
sinon une chapelle ça n'est pas non plus
une chapelle
peut-on visiter ce n'est pas aux
principes du genre d'endroit de ce genre
de choses qu'on visite mais qu'apportent
ses pittoresques
est ce un château ce n'est pas un
château no no no no puisqu'un japauto se
visite celle là ça fait partie du
paysage bien sûr mais ce n'est pas un
château d'apt il de l'époque romaine à
dire vrai nom à l'époque romaine ou
n'avait pas encore inventé ce genre de
choses
l espagnol oui effectivement celui en
principe que je représentais espagnol
top ten terminé pour notre deuxième
candidate troisième qui est je leur
rappelle un autre homme et face à
jean-marie voilier qui est le même homme
allons-y sommes-nous vivant à non nous
ne sommes plus vivants hélas mort depuis
très longtemps
oh oui quelques siècles je connais
importants par la taille
oui la grandeur oui en largeur - est-ce
que je me trouve sur un animal
ah oui bien sûr sur henan non sur un
cheval oui top j'ai l'impression qu'elle
peut-être peut-être on a fait un grand
en avant très sérieux là à strasbourg
alors utile peut-être une minute de
concertation jean-pierre vrai une petite
présentation de 15 secondes secondes oui
quand je dis une minute c'est un temps
vous êtes sûr donc je crois que c'est
vrai que nous sommes prêts très bien
alors première candidate qui êtes vous
suis-je painchaud oui m sochaux penseurs
on verra a dit oui avant que votre sang
fois deuxième candidate de lula au
moulin
et 3e n'y a pas de problème mais sinon
quichotte dont je dispose pour une fois
je suis pas d'avoir moins de trois
candidats qui vont se partager les 300
francs qui était l'enjeu de cette
histoire connelly bravo bravo bravo ils
sont très forts à strasbourg décidément
troisième jeu pour ce troisième jeu
également des candidats que je viens de
retrouver dans l'autre coin de notre
studio
ils sont au nombre de sept ans va donc
commencer par monsieur voilà ce jeu et
je le précise je prends je laisse c'est
à dire que robert rocca noir ikaria
jean-marie polje vont vous affirmez les
choses soient vraie soif aussi c'est
faux vous dites je laisse il c'est vrai
vous dites je prends c'est vraiment on
ne peut plus simple
5 bonnes réponses pour gagner ça c'est
important 5 bonnes réponses consécutives
premier candidat robert bonjour monsieur
bonjour bonsoir bonsoir ça va comme il
vous plaira est une comédie de musset
laisse le bakchich est un pourboire
persan je laisse vous n'auriez pas
d'aller prendre à vous n'auriez pas dû
alors candidat suivant et anne marie
carrière candidats suivants sarl
signifie sociétés à rendement limité
je laisse elle avait raison les
paupières de l'homme sont garnis de
poils je prends bien une marmite et et
le contenu d'une marmite
je laisse à nos il fallait prendre on
n'arrive pas aux cinquante fois enlacés
du rhum jean marie avec une copine est
loin quand madame si vous êtes porras et
si vous êtes porras et vous avez la
couleur du poireau oui je prends la les
fables de la fontaine sont divisé en
douze les ivre l'adultère et la
violation des devoirs je prends celui
qui est dit pod à deux pieds par dont
celui qui est dit pod à deux pieds or
vous auriez dû prendre deux petits pieds
je bats grand show
m maître capello oui d'accord
bon alors robert candidat suivant voir
moi je suis plus humain vous êtes vous
je ne vois pas la mignardise est un
petit oeil est je laisse à l'humanité de
revers a été très bref suivant que
robert une marinière est une blouse pour
manger des moules
non je laisse vous avez raison la
cimaise est une moulure je prends voilà
très bien un mari sts est voué à marie
mais non monsieur frère marié est voué à
la vierge marie
décidément ça va pas bien avec ce jeu là
alors jean marie comme je vais être
gentil
certains le le marmouset est un homme de
petite taille
je laisse aux vous auriez dû prendre la
suivante ça on doit la diplomatie donne
de l'aérophagie je laisse très bien
raison un rubis ballet et celui qu'on
trouve dans les balayures très vite je
laisse le larynx est un animal à l'oeil
perçant
je prends viège
je crois que c'est une erreur de reflex
à la narine on revient au départ oui
jean pierre avec le candidat monsieur
les marocains sont des portefeuilles je
me dois de vous signaler parce que c'est
pas écrit que ces marocains écrit avec
avec q je prends vous avez raison la
doucette et une salade
je prends la marraine de guerre donne le
baptême du feu l'os bien sûr on dit
n'importe quoi dans cette émission là
satinet est un petit pot la satim était
un petit pot je laisse vous avez raison
4 attention attention un cimetière
est un sabre turc je le sois là trois
premiers gagnants
voilà les premiers 50 points alors là
une fois c'est parti c'est parti
jean-marie grelier on continue le mari
de la can fait du jargon
je laisse à vous auriez duprat c'est le
cri du ja oui je ne le ferai pas parce
que c'est pas très joli mais le fait non
il sait pas il l'a fait je ne sais pas
ça du tout on ne peut pas aller madame
on ne peut pas aller dans un bal de tête
avec un habit à que je prends ça va nous
obliger à sortir ensemble ils n'avaient
pas de charge tout à l'heure la
marmaille et deux annonces de ben oui
c'est à ce jour le même demoiselle ou
l'autre oui la marmaille de la confiture
je laisse la véraison quand on est mari
mais célibataire on prend 2 r non je
vous laisse mais comment aussi
mademoiselle vous avez peur il fallait
prendre quand on est marie cm2 et
marie-mai ses libérateurs marie contre x
et enfin bon voilà ne 3 monsieur que
nous retrouvons pour jean-marie premier
abord est bien monsieur la baillie béa
et 2 a lieu est la femme du bailli je
laisse aux fallait la prendre là voulait
s'en débarrasser juste chantier avant
les kilomètres ah oui mais aujourd'hui à
bercy pour vite vite je veux le voir
parce que je peux pas il est là il est
là écoutez moi je vous apprends d'une
bonne chose le muscle poplité et dans le
jarret je laisse il est sous le genou à
l'asile en avant avec une faute de rugby
non je prends bon ben j'ai très bien le
pédiluve est un garçon de bains je
laisse aux bas vous avez raison la
paupiette est un plat je prends
l'apostrophent fait une fleur je laisse
à vous apportant encore une escrime est
un fait et à légumes
je laisse voilà olalalala repart pas
comment quand le temps ou encore moins
avec jamais encore je le lis chinois il
a gagné bon site à vous tuer là un
candidat le droit de montrer de votre le
lit chinois le lit chinois mesure 576 m
je laisse vous auriez dû prendre ça fait
un peu long doit enfin prendre son celi
et nelly mots croisés bon à nous anouma
dame qui voulait pas aller dans le monde
avec un habillage que c'est vous alors
on peut 2 on peut porter une a dû l'air
à l'annulaire non je lai bien vous avez
tort c'est une pierre fine j'allais vous
l'offrir pour aller au bal en question
voilà et bien je passe à jean marie poli
arrière mademoiselle la cigarière d'un
endroit où abondent les cigares jamais
on vous avez bien raison les corvidés
sont des animaux à cornes
je laisse vous avez raison le vrai tu
essaie d'avoir des petits le vrai tu es
je laisse non vous devriez prince
d'avoir des petits pour la femelle du
lierre voilà c'est terminé
eh bien nous avons deux gagnants
seulement oui oui deux gagnants curan
d'ipods oublie paix de regagner chacun
50 francs voilà et puis je crois qu'on
peut vous dire pourquoi nous avons ri et
pourquoi nous en appelons dire anne
marie carrière et pourquoi vous l'avez
pas revu au deuxième tour dernier tour
parce qu elle n'avait plus de questions
sur son petit papier et elle a inventé
comme ça brûle pourquoi les deux
dernières questions
c'est quand même une belle performance
la prochaine fois il y aura plus aucune
question écrite je crois que ce serait
tellement mieux voilà nous passons à
notre dernier jeu alors cette phrase de
maître capello avec un petit cochon de
14 100 francs qu'on a récupéré après son
escapade de tout à l'heure m nous avons
après bien peu de chose mais oui ce
n'est qu'il y à un mot que l'on peut
assimiler un objectif qu'on peut
assimiler assimiler un adulte voilà une
réserve où une audience légèrement
robert rocca avez vous une bonne idée du
jeu une idée la diversité m'a rendu
modeste pas tellement vous allez voir le
garçon que la téléspectatrice et le
téléspectateur ne refuse jamais sert
qu'à un chef de la claque et le clap man
ne sont presque jamais claqué technique
alors moi c'est très précis le roi
pozole la joconde et le canoë ne sont
pas que vous à germes présents pour le
roi nous sommes ravis de l'apprendre
savoir si vous êtes prêt à strasbourg
nous allons pouvoir attaquer bille en
tête m capello si j'ose dire
nous sommes prêts à lancer soit m soit
matin est ce que la négation plus se
trouve à la 11e place
il n'y a pas le mot plus mad arabe voilà
une bonne chose
14 100 francs toujours oui c'est à vous
m dangereux est ce que le mot canard est
à la deuxième place quel bon guide le
canard le canard non nous regrettons
l'absence du canal est ce que le mot de
était la troisième place 2 2e
préposition des oui non monsieur
faussaires paraît est-ce que la phrase
un repas un rapport avec strasbourg paul
ii - du monde et nous le regrettons
est ce que le i mode 8e mon camp et pas
vous voulez dire pop là s appropriant
négation non non il n'y a pas trois
comme l'avait déjà dit d'ailleurs on
avait dit plus un moment donné il à
l'envi en masse en bon fils mineur est
ce qu'il n'y ait de nouveau question
d'animaux nous avons dit qu'il n'ya pas
d'animaux dit s'il vous plaît autre
chose une autre question
sont ils tous au singulier et vous donne
également les noms oui mais non d'accord
donc les non contenue dans le texte sont
au singulier j'ajoute centre or à 1500
[Applaudissements]
il abattra il faut dire qu'il manque
tellement mots encore si difficiles vont
continuer à s'armer soit reçue est ce
qu'il y à un verbe dans la phrase car ça
nous avons déjà déposé nous aimons est
ce qu il a le verbe faire de la phrase
le verbe faire n'est pas dans la phrase
merci toujours 15 cents bonjour m parce
que le deuxième mot le premier moment
quand c'est une légumes légumes n'est
pas le premier momoka nous resterons à
15 cents francs et stoppons la cette
phrase de maître capello pour ce soir 14
200 francs que ces maigres que c'est
vrai que c'est maigre
qu'est ce que vous voulez espérons qu'il
va grossir un peu ce petit cochon dans
les jours à venir puisque demain nous
serons encore à strasbourg mais
attention demain nous serons à
strasbourg pour le dernier jour a alors
vous avez intérêt à vous dépêcher robert
rocca à bientôt j'espère bientôt maurice
ce soir bonsoir
derrière mon cher jean marie drot liés
au soir bonsoir strasbourg et bonsoir à
martin rebstock et à jean pierre
descombes à qui je souhaite une bonne
soirée
merci beaucoup marie c'est bonsoir à
vous tous nous donnons rendez vous à nos
candidats demain ce sera le dernier
jouet ou un trésor précise las de
bordeaux à fr3 alsace et le moto main et
le mot mort dont wii et vous retrouverez
ce mot dans les dernières nouvelles
d'alsace l'alsace nouvel alsacien et st
les flashs touche
pour vous trouverez également dans ses
journaux une grille qui pourra vous
aider je l'espère alors jean pierre je
termine en alsacien en disant bis amen
salut aux arabes aujourd'hui dix ans à
demain soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]